we we do have some good news though I
mean it's kind of good news that's kind
of bad news but there's a light at the
end of the tunnel here's what there's
you know door closes and a window opens
we got the story from timcast.com White
House spins Department of Education
blames random error for document
promoting critical race Theory this fall
and we also saw Jen sackey Challenge on
this so the original story was that the
Biden administration's guidelines for
schools reopening this fall is backing a
radical groups literature that promotes
anti-racism training in public
classrooms across the country now we got
to break down that word anti-racism
because if you are unlearned you may
just assume these code words these dog
whistles just to mean what it means on
the surface no anti-racism according to
ibram x Kendy is racial discrimination
quite literally you think it's
anti-racism like people aren't going to
be arrested no no he wants them to
discriminate in the basis of race what
he's saying is that like he let's put it
this way if racism is negative is is
plus one and not being racist is zero
anti-racism is negative one yes it is it
is a value in Mirror Image to racism
that serves the same function but for a
somewhat different ideology that being
what he claims is if we are anti-racist
meaning we actually implement the exact
same policies of the past
but we do it it'll be better this time
and that just as far as I'm concerned
it's just literally racism so the good
news I suppose is that the Biden admin
has backtracked after sparking a major
backlash on social media regarding
critical race Theory blaming a random
error for a government guy that promoted
a far left group and their agenda we
have this from The Daily Mail jenseki
claims it was an error to promote the
group that urges teachers to disrupt
whiteness and oppression after
Republicans accused the Biden admin of
flip-flopping now this is good news
apparently the Democrats are starting to
get scared of wokeness there was a story
in axios we saw the victory of Eric
Adams in New York City they're worried
they're going to lose the midterms
because yeah well go broke yeah
yeah I mean it's it's funny you bring up
Eric Adams because he was in New York
City you would think oh
um there were there were a couple of
really woke candidates Maya Wiley was a
was a big vote candidate in New York
City and you would think oh the the
black Americans and Hispanic Americans
would vote for the vote candidate they
didn't they voted for the candidate Eric
Adams who promised uh more police not
less police he promised Public Safety he
said I'm going to make crime my number
one issue I'm gonna make education as my
my second best biggest issue because the
New York public system is so poor and
it's not because of funding it's not
because of what the teachers unions say
which is oh we need more resources did
you know that New York City
funds uh funds students twenty eight
thousand dollars a year 28 they spend
twenty eight thousand dollars a year per
student which is the highest in the
nation so it's not about funding but uh
Eric Adams you know said hey look we
need to restore the culture of these
schools so they actually voted uh for in
my opinion the candidate that that
um did that that represented you know
the least excesses of wokeness
fortunately yeah and I'm not surprised I
mean we saw what happened in South Texas
we saw what happened in in Miami you
know of course that was likely you know
Hispanic individuals with experience
with Communism and Marxism but uh the
other day we had uh Ricardo and Jose
lamasan and Jose he's he's a he's an
older gentleman he actually was in the
anti-fidel Castro underground in Cuba
and he said he said some scary stuff he
said that if black lives matter gets
real power they're gonna kill people he
said that these people are Marxist
they're they're enemies from within
they're scary and I'm like man this is a
guy with the flee Cuba because of what
happened now that is freaky the
difference between Cuba and the United
States however is that we got several
hundred million people here right now we
got what like a you know 170 or so
million active voters
so these are a lot of people that I
don't think would allow the the as you
described the excess of wokism to become
too pervasive now what does it mean to
be too pervasive well let's be fair it's
pervasive it's in institutions it's in
video games but I think people are
starting to recoil from this that's why
Joe Biden the administration had to
backtrack they're getting worried I'm
hoping that's the case I'm hoping they
realize they are poisoning their party
with this stuff I hope they're realizing
they will lose elections unless they get
away from this but I also have to add
they're never getting my vote back
anyway they've crossed they crossed the
the Rubicon as it were they went nuts
like hardcore insane and now they want
to come back and be like oh no yeah nice
try dude I'm not I'm not I'm not gonna
gonna play that game with these people
you look at you look at New York you
look what people wanted they wanted the
x-cop Eric Adams right right yeah and
you know it's it's funny because during
the campaign
if you remember Biden during 2020
campaign Biden was pressured to say
defund the police and he he did not say
defund the police and I I'm convinced
that if he went and crossed that line
and he said yeah we're gonna go defund
the police I'm probably I'm convinced
that you know even more Trump voters you
know even even you know the voters that
he supposedly won back from Trump would
have stayed with Trump
um yeah that would have been would have
been the it would be it would be over
right right right but now unfortunately
you can see you can see of course
promises were made promises were not
kept
um Rob Biden you know is growing old
he's growing seniles letting Kamala
Harris take over more of his
administration what promises were not
kept well uh this this idea of of Biden
saying that he claims to be the unifier
the unifying candidate I will unify
America instead he's pushing divisive
race ideology it's not even that he he
said we he was basically he basically
was talking about the divide in this
country and how that it is first of all
he launched his campaign on a lie
Charlottesville yep the the very fine
people hoax he just absolutely rammed
that line on people's throat because
he's a scumbag and now he says you know
we need we need to unify you know we
need to come together and it's like dude
just went on and gave a speech where he
said the Republicans voting legislation
is the greatest threat since the Civil
War you want to talk about bombastic and
divisive language sure we can talk about
critical race Theory how about the
president of the United States coming up
and saying Republican agenda is a bigger
threat to the Confederacy he's that's
what he literally said dudes lost his
mind yeah but the central banking system
is more of a threat fiat currency the 28
trillion and national debt The Runaway
inflation he's claiming it's not runaway
it's like kind of like what was his
exact words any guys remember off top of
your head he was like it's okay it's
just inflation it's going to get back to
normal she said something like this will
not increase inflation he said that I
think three times in a row because he's
super with it as we all know
um but I was like there's no way that
you can look at this and say that
inflation is not coming in fact Janet
Yellen has even said yeah we expect some
form of inflation
look we can survive inflation we can we
can make it past our milk costing more
money and that it sucks I mean he's got
no Solutions he's mocking these business
owners like he I I believe he's
essentially mocking them but I'll tell
you
we we can get through that and we can
argue about it combine that combine a
massive escalation in the cost of food
with Joe Biden saying the Republican
agenda is the greatest threat since the
Civil War
this guy is flicking matches at a powder
keg
we talked about last night with Jose
Lamas about uh the Cuban Revolution how
Castro betrayed the Revolution and
essentially took it uh didn't didn't
install their their democracy and I
asked them what what could we have done
differently or what could they have done
differently in 1960 that would have
prevented he said not to to be more
patient not to take not to revolt
against Batiste because what they
thought was Batista was running for
election again and they thought it was
going to be rigged so they were like
they had a preemptive Revolution to get
this guy out of this before he could so
this I could see something like that
happening in this country with all this
divisiveness people thinking there's
election issues that people would act
impatiently and I think it's it's up to
us to stay you know calm even if the
system seems flawed that we you know
remain and work within the system you
see you see Joe Biden said the other day
as well that he wants to he's working to
ban any weapon with the ability to take
multiple rounds yeah wow huh he
basically let's be real he was not very
articulate but he wanted to say what
weapons that can take multiple rounds
like 20 30 40 50 120 you don't need them
and I'm working hard to ban them and now
I know a lot of people on the left are
going to try and play this game I should
I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm gonna walk that
back I know a lot of the establishment
Democrats because leftists actually like
guns are going to play this game where
they're like oh he didn't mean Banning
every gun oh he meant this I don't care
what you think he meant because y'all
can't read his mind he said it yeah so
if you're talking about a weapon that
can take a detachable magazine then you
can have a variety of magazines of sizes
that's what he's talking about the
Democrats have long said they want to
ban semi-automatic weapons why should I
believe Biden meant something else
I bring that up yeah because one of the
other things that Jose mentioned about
Cuba was that Fidel Castro came out and
said the famous question Guns For What
and everyone was like yeah for what and
then they throw all their guns into a
pile and then the Communists took over
and they got to live under a boot for
the next several Generations
yeah right yeah yeah I mean you know
it's crazy I mean you know the funny
thing is you know you go to China and
China of course the Communist Party
um has a has a huge Monopoly over the
arms over arms and everything like that
and not only do they have Monopoly of
arms they have increased their Monopoly
to surveillance and now they can surveil
you you know for for whatever thing so
now they control the arms they control
you know your actions that can control
your thoughts you know and they can
incentivize you based on your thoughts
this is the whole idea of like a social
currency they have a social currency
system in China now and it's like this
is the direction that we are progressing
as a country and people think oh it's
just guns it's not a big deal you know
we just you know that kind of thing
that's what progressives think but you
realize that guns is the linchpin it's
the physical linchpin that is able to
defend all the rest of the rights that
we hold so dear this is what the these
uh these establishment diamonds don't
understand right these establishment
voters these default Libs they're like
you know Joe Biden says you're gonna
need an F-15 and nukes to go up against
the government that's not true there's a
reason why we don't have to a certain
degree Jack boot Biden thugs kicking
doors in and dragging people out by
their hair especially over covet and
lockdowns but you do see things like
that in Australia and New Zealand and
Canada and the UK there's a reason uh
why it's a little better here it's not
perfect we absolutely do have cops will
kick your door in and then you know
arrest you or just suit you but the
thing is the fact that so many Americans
have guns makes it extremely difficult
to violate human rights because you
never know if you're going to encounter
someone who can be able to defend
themselves it equalizes a little bit of
the power between the government and the
individual so that they have to go
through the proper emotions it's not
hard for our government to oppress you
using bureaucracy it's actually very
easy however gun ownership protects you
a little bit
and in the in the long run if done
properly can protect a nation forever so
long as you don't end up with people
saying the stupid question guns for what
which is what they're doing over and
over and over what do you need a gun for
we need a gun for and I'm like none of
your business who cares
I don't need to give you an answer
the founding fathers kind of put uh the
Second Amendment into place because they
expected the government to grow and grow
and grow as governments do like they
would talk about we're not a bunch of
men governed by Angels were men governed
by men they understood the shortcomings
they're like okay the government's going
to grow we need to kind of put citizens
on a slightly more even playing field
and that was unique like you didn't see
that in Cuba when this is going on
didn't see that in Mao's China this is
something that we need to pay attention
to this is not something that we can
afford to lose so so I don't want to say
this is pessimistic a lot of people seem
to think that when I talk about
escalation in a conflict it's pessimism
and I'm like don't don't take it to a
dark place it's realism right thanks for
checking out this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast if you want to see the full
show come back to this channel
youtube.com
timcastirl Monday through Friday at 8 pm
where you can leave comments and Super
Chat and we actually will read your
comments on the show don't forget to
like share subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else go to
timcast.com become a member and we even
have full bonus episodes thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time